[Música]
Olá
pessoal, tudo bem? Muito boa noite a
todos vocês. É um prazer estar com vocês
novamente.
Vamos, como é de prche responder as
perguntas que vocês deixaram no
documento e discutir mais alguns
assuntos. Um assunto que eu achei
interessante, que foi motivo de uma das
perguntas, é sobre a nicotina, né, como
agente terapêutico, né, uma coisa ainda
meio questionável, inclusive eu vou
falar sobre isso, achei a pergunta muito
pertinente, então nós vamos nos estender
um pouco mais nessa pergunta.
Bem, a primeira pergunta do de hoje
é sobre o vídeo que eu vi sobre o câncer
de mama. Na verdade, são duas perguntas
sobre esse vídeo.
A primeira pergunta é sobre o BCG
sonicado.
Então, pediram para eu falar mais sobre
isso, como é que é utilizado no
protocolo e se o BCG poderia ser
utilizado para outros tipos de câncer,
fora o câncer de mama. Então, essa
pergunta é muito pertinente,
é um assunto realmente que eu nunca
abordei num canal.
O BCG sonicado,
ele é um item que é especificamente o
bacilos Calmet Guerin, né, que é o o
bacilo que é utilizado para fazer a
vacina contra a tuberculose,
que foi submetido ao processo de
sonicação. O que que é uma técnica?
Utiliza ondas ultrassônicas para romper
mecanicamente as células bacterianas, a
parede bacteriana, criando assim
fragmentos celulares que também pode ser
chamado de lisados.
Então, a diferença entre o BCG
tradicional, que é utilizado como
vacina, e o BCG sonicado, é que o
primeiro utiliza os bacilos vivos
atenuados, enquanto o segundo trabalha
com componentes bacterianos
fragmentados.
Então a gente com essa técnica de
sonicação, isso permite que obtenhamos
os benefícios imunomoduladores
sem risco de utilizar bactérias vivas
atenuadas.
Então, nesse protocolo para câncer, o
BCG sonicado, ele funciona como um
potente estimulador imunológico. Ele
através da apresentação de antígenos
bacterianos, né, desses fragmentos do
BCG, que ativam as células dendríticas,
tá, que vão se diferenciar depois em
macrófagos.
também ativa linfócitos T e outras
células do sistema imune. Então, os
fragmentos da parede celular do BCG,
especialmente o esqueleto da parede
celular, que tem essa sigla CWS,
então BCG ifen CWS.
Então esse esqueleto da parede celular
tem moléculas como glicolipídios
e lipoglicanos,
tendo uma que é um tipo de açúcar, e
estimula a resposta imune do tipo TH1.
Então eu é um tipo de linfócito T, TH1
através da produção de TNF alfa e
teleocina 12 e terferongama
em relação a outros tipos de câncer que
não seja de mama.
A literatura científica demonstrou
aplicações do BCG sonicado e seus
derivados em diversos contextos
oncológicos. Então, estudos mais
robustos incluem o tratamento de câncer
de pulmão, onde o esqueleto da parede
celular do BCG
demonstrou prolongamento significativo
da sobrevida quando utilizado na forma
de imunoterapia adjuvante. E também
temos evidência de eficácia no caso do
melanoma maligno,
carcinoma ou câncer de próstata e até
mesmo em carcinomas de células escamosas
de olho. Isso em modelos bovinos, não em
humano. Então, mama, pulmão,
melanoma
e próstata.
Então, a preparação nanoparticulada do
BCG CWS, ele representa um avanço
significativo e permite a administração
sistêmica pela veia intravenosa, o que
expande de forma significativa as
possibilidades terapêuticas para
cânceres ali na bexiga, onde
tradicionalmente se fazia o BCG na forma
intravesical.
No contexto do câncer de mama,
especificamente, estudos mais recentes
indicam que os lisados tumorais oxidados
combinados com componentes do BCG podem
criar vacinas personalizadas autólogas
extremamente eficazes,
estimulando tanto a resposta moral
quanto celular contra os antígenos
tumorais específicos. Ou seja, você pega
célula tumoral, mistura com BCG e faz
uma vacina personalizada para aquela
pessoa. Então, o tumor daquela pessoa
misturado com o BCG entregue à própria.
Então o protocolo que mencionamos, né,
utiliza então essas propriedades
imunomoduladoras do BCG sonicado como
parte de uma abordagem integrada,
buscando então potencializar a resposta
imunatural
contra as células tumorais, enquanto
minimizamos os efeitos adversos
associados ao uso de bactérias vivas
atenuadas.
OK? Então está aí a resposta à pergunta.
Boa noite, Maria Helena. Boa noite,
Alice Vogel. À medida que vocês forem
entrando, por favor, dê o seu alô e
também me responda o seu áudio, está OK?
Próxima pergunta. Ainda sobre o vídeo
Câncer de Mama, os melhores suplementos.
A artemísia poderia ter o seu efeito
potencializado com a ingestão do
suplemento de ferro
com intuito de potencializar a
ferroptose
das células cancerígenas? É uma boa
pergunta, mas
o que acontece é que o ferro em excesso
ele é um produto complicado. O ferro em
excesso ele acaba provocando mais
estresse oxidativo através da reação de
fenton.
Então, a artemísia juntamente com seus
derivados, como é o caso da artemisina
ou artemisinina,
já tem um mecanismo muito eficiente de
potencialização da ferroptose
que depende da suplementação externa de
ferro. Então, eu não recomendaria fazer
o ferro junto, tá? Os estudos de 2024,
2025 mostram que a Artemísia atua
aumentando significativamente os níveis
de ferro livre intracelular através de
vários mecanismos. Primeiro, ela promove
a degradação lisossomal
da ferritina de forma independente da
autofagia,
liberando ferro armazenado dentro da
célula. Então, segundo, ela interfere no
sistema regulatório IRP/IRE,
que controla a homeostase do ferro
celular, levando um acúmulo ainda maior
de ferro livre nas células. Então, o
aspecto fundamental aqui é que a
artemísia não apenas disponibiliza o
ferro, mas também se associa com ferro
livre celular de uma forma que mantenha
sua atividade oxidativa, mas impede que
seja reconhecido pelos mecanismos
regulatórios da célula.
Isso cria uma situação de a célula
cancerígena fica cega ao excesso de
ferro intracelular e não consegue ativar
as defesas antioxidantes de forma
adequada.
Em relação ao câncer de mama de forma
específica, os estudos demonstram que a
diidroartisinina
aumentou significativamente a
sensibilidade à ferroptose em linhagem
células de câncer de mama, sem
necessidade de ferro adicional. E a
suplementação externa de ferro, como eu
disse, levanta algumas preocupações,
principalmente pelo fato do ferro ser um
agente oxidativo em excesso e poderia
estar afetando as células normais não
cancerígenas.
Os estudos 2020 a 2024 indicam que o
ferro suplementado poderia interferir
negativamente na resposta imune
antitumoral, particularmente nas funções
dos linfócitos T, CD4 e CD8.
infiltrantes do tumor. Então, poderia
atrapalhar a própria ação das células
imunes destruindo a o tumor. Além disso,
a evidência de que o ferro pode
estimular angiogênese tumoral através do
aumento da expressão do VGF, que é o
fator de crescimento endotelial, tá?
o vascular endotilial growth factor. O
mais interessante é que a artemísia já
sensibiliza células resistentes à
ferroptose, tornando-se um
potencializador natural e direcionado.
Então, estudos mostram que mesmo células
de câncer altamente resistentes à
inibição da GPX4
se tornam suscetíveis quando tratadas
com derivados de artemísia. Então, a
recomendação que eu faço é que não
associe o ferro à Artemísia.
É melhor focar na otimização da
biodisponibilidade e absorção da própria
Artemísia.
Obrigado pelo aviso, Alice, do áudio.
Próxima pergunta. Ainda sobre o vídeo,
câncer de mamos melhora os suplementos.
O sal de carpanen poderia ser
substituído pelo sal integral mais o
suplemento de iodo.
Uma boa pergunta. A resposta é que não é
equivalente, tá? O sal iodado não é
equivalente ao sol carpanemen. Então vou
explicar as diferenças.
O sol de carpanen, ele tem uma
composição bem específica. Ele tem 57%
de cloreto de sódio, 28% de cloreto de
potássio, 12% de sulfato magnésio, 2% de
cloridrato de lisina, que é aminoácido,
e 1% de dióxido de silício e 0,0036%
de iodo. Então essa formulação foi
desenvolvida pelo Dr. Carpanen
especificamente para reduzir o sódio
enquanto mantém os benefícios dos
minerais essenciais. Já o sal integral,
que é o caso sal rosa, ele contém
aproximadamente 98% de clorito de sódio
e 2% de minerais traços diversos. da
concentração de potássio e magnésio é
muito menor comparado ao sal carpanen.
Sobre i odo de maneira específica, no
contexto do câncer de mama, as pesquisas
mais recentes em 2024 confirmam que iodo
tem efeito protetor contra o câncer de
mama, especialmente quando combinado com
o selênio. Então, os estudos mostram que
o iodo molecular pode atuar como
adjuvante na quimioterapia, reduzindo a
resistência tumoral e melhorando a
sobrevida livre de doença. A deficiência
de iodo está associado a o aumento do
risco de câncer de mama com doença
distante em mulheres jovens. Então, o
iodo ele atua tanto diretamente no
tecido mamário quanto indiretamente
através da função tiroidiana.
Então, se você quisesse fazer a
substituição do sal carpan pelo sal com
iodo, seria necessário você usar o sal
integral com baixo teor de sódio, que eu
não conheço,
suplementar separadamente com magnésio e
potássio nas proporções adequadas,
adicionar o suplemento de iodo,
preferencialmente o iodo molecular, e
considerar a suplementação de selene
para potencializar os efeitos do iodo. E
o sal de carpen já tem essa formulação
otimizada, então daria muito mais
trabalho você tentar montar isso sozinho
do que você comprar o sal de carpita na
manipulação,
certo?
Então é, seria essa a resposta. Próxima
pergunta, querido amigo, por favor, qual
seriam, quais seriam, né, os melhores
filtros que retirem fluor, cloro,
microplásticos, metais pesados e
patógenos? Qual a medida de duração do
refio e o valor total? Uma outra
questão, o hidrapuri realmente
alcaliniza a água? Por fim, qual a
diferença de água ozonizada, hidrogênio
e molecular? Desde já agradeço. Foi um
imenso prazer finalmente conhecer
pessoalmente na consulta que minha mãe
teve com a Dra. Ana também para mim foi
um prazer te encontrar aqui no
consultório, tá? Um grande abraço.
Então, vou responder as suas perguntas.
Eh, filtros que eu falo em vídeos no
canal do YouTube. Depois você pode dar
uma olhada. Eu tenho um vídeo sobre água
lá que eu falo dos filtros, tá? Então, a
gente recomenda o filtro Kanem.
Ele é
uma linha de filtros considerada bem
eficaz na limpeza de água. Remove metais
pesados, remove o fluor através de um
processo de ionização, equilibra o pH da
água, OK?
É um filtro de custo elevado, tá? Deve
tá uma faixa de R$ 10, R$ 15.000.
Filtros à base de ozônio, tem o Top
Life. Esse filtro remove impurezas e
utiliza o ozônio para eliminar vírus,
bactérias e fungos. Porém, não tem essa
prerrogativa de tirar metais pesados e
fluor ou microplástico, tá? Mas seria
uma boa opção com preço intermediário.
Aí você tem os filtros da Aqualive.
Eles são fabricados com materiais como
acrílico ou vidro para eliminar a
contaminação por plásticos.
Esses fios também são considerados boas
opções de preço médio, só que também não
remove totalmente microplástico
e metal pesado. Filtros com velas de
carvão ativado são uma alternativa mais
econômica, reduz as impurezas e alguns
modelos utilizam a prata coloidal para
eliminar microorganismos.
Então, podem ser utilizados em filtros
de barro ou acrílico. Também é outro
problema, não vai eliminar microplástico
ou metais pesados. Filtros de osmose
reversa. Esses são os top, também são os
mais caros
e são capazes de eliminar todos os
contaminantes, incluindo minerais e
fluor, produzindo uma água altamente
purificada, geralmente é uma água
destilada, então tem um processo de
filtragem mais lento, desperdiçam
bastante água e após a purificação, tem
muita gente que recomenda repor os
minerais que foram retirados, mas isso é
um assunto também um pouco polêmico. Tem
aí pessoas, como é o caso doutor,
o doutor me fugiu o nome dele agora.
Bem, tem um médico fala muito sobre água
hidrogenada, hidrogenada não, água
destilada, né? O Braguini, Carlos
Braguini Júnior, lembrei agora, o Carlos
Bragini Júnior, ele fala muito que não é
um problema tomar água destilada, tá?
Então isso é uma coisa que depende da
opinião.
Tem umas marcas aí também adicionais
para comentar que eu não falei no vídeo.
que é o purifique low fluor, que remove
88% do fluor e 99,99%
dos vírus e bactérias, 90% dos metais
pesados, tem sete camadas de
purificação, tem um carvão ativado
especial, tem resinas ctiônicas, tem
magnetos, tem infravermelho e sai uma
alga alcalina de pH próximo de nove aí,
tá? E esse produto parece ter um preço
mais em conta. O refil dele custa por
volta de R$ 200.
Ele foi testado pela Universidade
Estadual de Maringá. Então, purifique
low fluor. Essa máquina eu não conhecia
quando eu fui fazer a pesquisa para
responder essa pergunta.
Global Filter também é outra que eu não
conhecia. Remove cloro, fluo, metais
pesados através de múltiplas mídias. Tem
um carvão ativado com prata coloidal,
tem resinas aniônicas e catiônicas. tem
um sistema central para a casa toda ou
modelos pontuais,
né? Então isso aqui seria um modelo com
custo benefício para famílias grandes,
né? Para filtragem central.
Agora sobre o Hidrapuri, né, que ele
tava perguntando, né? Baseada na análise
do site do Hidrapuri, ele alcalinizaria
a água através de turmalina negra e
cerâmica alcalina. Aumentaria o pH.
magnetismo que aumentaria a
condutividade elétrica, e um sistema
ctiônico que reduziria a dureza da água.
E o refio duraria para 400 L ou 4 meses
de uso e tornaria essa água então
alcalina com pH acima de sete, mas não
especifica os valores exatos do pH. Eu
não tenho experiência pessoal com esse
hidrapuri, tá? Então, tô passando
informações baseadas no que eu
pesquisei.
Pergunta sobre a água ozonizada versus
hidrogênio molecular. São coisas
diferentes. A água ozonizada é uma água
onde foi dissolvido ios de
ozônio, tá? Então, o que que é o ozônio?
É um oxidante poderoso, né? O ozônio
você sabe que é
três moléculas de oxigênio juntas.
Então o ozônio ele tem efeito
proxidativo. Em pequenas concentrações,
esse efeito proxidativo, o organismo
contra uma balança com efeito
antioxidante.
O ozônio pode desinfectar e eliminar
patógenos. tem esse efeito antioxidante
em pequenas doses porque é o efeito de
hormese, né, de reação do organismo.
A meia vida da água ozonizada de 15 a 20
minutos em em temperatura ambiente.
Ah, a desvantagem é que pode prejudicar
microbiota intestinal benéfica.
Não é para uso de ar, mas seria para um
uso terapêutico pontual.
A água com hidrogênio molecular é outra
coisa, porque o hidrogênio dissolvido
nessa água é um antioxidante seletivo,
neutraliza radicais livres, atravessa a
barreira mata encefálica, poderia
preservar a microbiota e benéfica e é
seguro para consumo de ário. Então, para
consumo diário, eu recomendo o uso do
hidrogênio molecular na água e não o
ozônio, não água ozonizada, tá?
Como é um antioxidante, o hidrogênio tem
ação antiflamatória comprovada.
Então, basicamente, o ozônio oxida e o
hidrogênio reduz o estresse oxidativo.
Lógico, quando você faz um ozônio
intrarretal, por exemplo, né, ozônio
retal,
eh, o efeito final no organismo é de
aumento da antioxidação, mas é o efeito
de hormese, tá? Lógico, se o ozônio
tiver muito concentrado, o efeito vai
ser mais proxidativo.
Então, o hidrogênio molecular, ele é
superior para uso diário porque ele é um
antioxidante seletivo, protege células
benéficas enquanto neutraliza radicais
livres nocivos.
Certo? Próxima pergunta.
Doutor, uma pessoa tomando os remédios
convencionais para Paxon poderia
teoricamente,
digo teoricamente porque mesmo que
possa, cada caso é único, mas então
teoricamente poderia tomar juntamente
também com adjuvantes a mucuna pruriens.
Então, baseado na literatura mais
recente desse ano e do ano passado,
teoricamente sim é possível usar mocuna
prurians concomitantemente com os
medicamentos convencionais, mas tem
algumas considerações importantes que
nós precisamos discutir aqui. A mucuna
contém de 4 a 6% de levodopa natural nas
sementes, que é exatamente o mesmo
precipativo do medicamento convencional
levodopa.
Os estudos mais recentes mostram que ela
pode ter algumas vantagens, tá? Início
de ação mais rápido, duração mais
prolongada de efeito e potencialmente
menos dissinesias quando comparado ao
uso do levodopa barra carbidopa
tradicional, tá? Então teria algumas
vantagens aí, especialmente a ação mais
rápida, a duração mais prolongada e
menos de sinesias. teve um estudo
randomizado controlado desse ano,
publicado no Journal of
Neurotransmission,
que confirmou esses benefícios
farmacocinéticos.
Teve outro estudo sistemático recente
que analisou todos os ensaios clínicos
disponíveis e confirmou a eficácia da
mocuna.
Agora, as considerações importantes.
Primeiro, como a mucuna contém levodopa,
ela essencialmente está adicionando mais
do mesmo agente, né, ao tratamento. Isso
significa que existe o risco de
sobredosagem dopaminfica se não houver
ajustes nas doses convencionais. Houve
um caso recente relatado em 2024 no
Journal of Movement Disorders, que
mostrou a um paciente que desenvolveu
síndrome de desregulação dopaminica.
porque usou excessivamente a mocuna.
E o segundo ponto importante aqui, que a
mocuna não contém carbidopa ou
benzerida, que são os inibidores da
descarboxilase
que estão presentes no medicamentos
convencionais. Isso significa que a
biodisponibilidade da levodópa da mocuna
pode ser diferente, potencialmente
menor, mas também pode ter um perfil de
absorção diferente. Terceiro ponto que a
concentração da ledidopa na mocuna pode
variar entre vários fornecedores ou
lotes, então torna a dosagem meio
imprevisível,
diferente dos medicamentos padronizados.
Então, na prática clínica, alguns
colegas têm usado a mocuna como ponte
entre as doses convencionais,
especialmente em pacientes com fenômeno
de wearing off, mas sempre com
monitorização rigorosa. Então, um caso
relatado em 2024 mostrou melhora do
tempo on utilizando essa estratégia.
Então, o que que eu recomendo para quem
tem interesse? começar com doses muito
baixas de mucuna, que seria o
equivalente a 25 a 50 mg de eleidopa,
preferencialmente reduzindo
proporcionalmente a medicação
convencional, sempre com acompanhamento
médico especializado, e observação
cuidadosa de sinais de excesso
dopaminético, como as de cinesias
aumentadas, alucinações ou
comportamentos compulsivos. Então, dá
para usar com cautela, com muito
cuidado, né?
Sim, em conjunto. Porém, eu acredito que
a maioria dos neurologistas não se
sentiriam confortáveis com essa
combinação.
Próxima pergunta. Prezado Dr. Alan. A
vitamina E precisa ser suplementação ou
é possível com consumo de azeite e
oleaginosas
conseguir uma boa dosagem? Quais seriam
os alimentos e quantidades?
Outra pergunta. Na medicina iurveda se
utiliza recipientes de cobre para água.
Isso pode gerar intoxicação. Quais são
as vantagens? Por fim, usar pedras de
enxofre na água traz benefícios?
Mais uma vez, muito obrigado por todo o
seu trabalho de valor inestimável.
Obrigado pelos seus comentários.
Vamos lá, então. Pela literatura do ano
passado, 2024, a vitamina E nas oito
formas e nas oitos vitâmeros
pode ser obtido através de fontes
alimentares. O principal delas é o
urucum.
Pode ser também o extrato lá do do
arroz, também é uma fonte de vitamina E.
tem algumas considerações a fazer sobre
isso. A necessidade RDA de vitamina E,
se a gente for considerar só um dos
vitâmeros, né, que é o alfa tocoferol,
um dos oito, seria de 15 mg de alfa
tocoferol por dia. Uma colher de sopa de
azeite extravadamente
20% da recomendação diária, ou seja,
cerca de 2,8 mg.
Para atingir a recomendação completa
através do azeite, seria necessário
consumir cerca de 60 ml diários, que são
quatro colheres de sopa, uma quantidade
que já é próxima dessas recomendações aí
da necessidade diária de vitamina E.
As oliaas são excelentes fontes também.
30 g de amêndoas fornece cerca de 7,3 mg
e 30 g de semente girassol.
oferece aproximadamente 10 mg.
A grande vantagem das fontes
alimentares, né, é que fornecem todo o
complexo das oito formas, tocoferóois e
tocotrenois, não apenas o alfa
tocoferol. E estudos recentes mostram
que os outros compostos também têm
funções metabólicas importantes. Então,
a suplementação isolada pode ser
considerada em casos específicos de má
absorção ou deficiências comprovadas.
Agora indo para pergunta do cobre. Então
a prática aurveda do tanra Jal, né, que
é o uso dessas vasilhas de cobre, tem
respaldo científico.
Estudos de 2024 confirmam o efeito
oligodinâmico do cobre com capacidade
antimicrobiana contra a esquericha,
vibriocoléria, né, que é o bichinho da
cólera, salmonela e outras bactérias
patogênicas. Isso a partir de 16 horas
de contato com cobre. Então o limite
seguro de cobre, segundo a OMS, seria de
0,47 mg do mineral por copo de água.
Então, pesquisas mostram que mesmo após
16 horas de armazenamento, a quantidade
de cobre liberada permanece bem abaixo
dos limites de segurança. Então, poderia
usar sim esses esses recipientes, sem
problema. Então, a recomendação iuveda
de dois a três copos por dia estaria
dentro dos parâmetros seguros. Quanto
intoxicação, ela poderia ocorrer com
exposição prolongada, altas doses ou
água estagnada em tubulações corruídas,
né? Isso não é, seria o caso você usar
esse esses vasilhames aí daveda. Então,
sinais de excesso de cobre seria
náusees, vômitos, diarreia, em casos
severos, dano ao fígado e aos rins,
tá? Então, poderia utilizar esses
frascos tranquilamente.
Então, quais seria as vantagens de usar
esses recipientes de cobre? Purificação
natural da água, propriedades
antioxidantes,
estímulo à produção da hemoglobina e,
segundo a tradição aurveda, equilíbrio
dos dochas.
E seria importante utilizar recipientes
de cobre puro sem revestimentos internos
que impeçam o contato da água com metal.
Sobre o enxofre na água, né, as pedras
de enxofre,
existe já uma tradição milenar com as
águas sulfurosas
dentro do que a gente conhece como
medicina termal. A literatura de 2024
mostra que os benefícios estão
relacionados principalmente ao sulfeto
de hidrogênio, que é liberado em baixas
concentrações. Então, estudos recentes
demonstram efeitos anti-inflamatórios,
antioxidantes e de e de sinalização
celular, né, do sulfeito de hidrogênio
em doses fisiológicas.
As pesquisas mostram benefícios para
pressão alta, aterosclerose,
lesões de isquimia, reperfusão, que
acontece, por exemplo, nos casos aí de
infarto do miocárdio e doenças
inflamatórias crônicas. Então, mecanismo
envolve a produção de glutationa, que é
o nosso antioxidante master, né, ou
endógeno mais potente, e modulação de
vias inflamatórias. Porém, é fundamental
entender que há uma janela terapêutica
que é estreita. Se você errar na dose do
sulfeto de hidrogênio, ele passa a ser
extremamente tóxico se for em altas
concentrações comparável ao cianeto.
Então, para uso seguro tem que respeitar
o pH, preferencialmente ácido, baixas
concentrações de oxigênio para a
estabilidade do composto e sempre
supervisão de um profissional
experiente. Então, a automedicação com
pedras de enxofre pode ser sim perigosa
devido à impossibilidade de controlar a
concentração final.
Então, é muito importante ter cautela
com esse método, porque a diferença
entre dose terapêutica e tóxica é muito
pequena, então não recomendo você fazer
isso em casa sozinho, tá?
Então é melhor você utilizar as águas
termais naturais, né? porque elas têm
concentrações baixas e bem estabelecidas
do sulfeto de hidrogênio. Não tente
fazer esse sulfeto de hidrogênio em
casa.
Próxima pergunta. É verdade que a
berberina reduz os efeitos da mformina
quando se toma berberina 500 mg pela
manhã e noite e no almoço 500 mg de
berberina?
Não, não é verdade, tá? Vou explicar
porquê.
A relação entre berberina e metiformina
é, na verdade, mais complexa do que
simplesmente reduzir e aumentar os
efeitos. Os estudos mais recentes
mostram que existe sim uma interação
farmacológica entre esses dois
compostos, mas o resultado final pode
ser tanto benéfico quanto supostamente
problemático. Eu vou explicar para vocês
porque eu acho que é muito mais benéfico
do que problemático,
mas vai depender de como são
administrados. Então, a Bebelina
interfere nos transportadores de cá
orgânicos que são responsáveis pelo
transporte da mitiformina. Então,
teoricamente, quando você toma os dois
juntos, um atrapalha o outro.
Então, especificamente, a beberina
inibiria os transportadores,
tá? E isso significa que ela poderia
alterar tanto a absorção quanto a
eliminação da mediformina. Só que na
prática o que acontece é quando você
toma a beberina junto com a metiformina,
ela pode aumentar na verdade as
concentrações do sangue da metiformina e
não diminuir. Isso ocorreria porque a
beberina interfere na eliminação renal
da metiformina através do dos
transportadores mat1 e mat,
fazendo com que mais metiformina
permaneça no organismo. Então, estudos
recentes, incluindo um do ano passado,
que foi publicado na Scientific Reports,
mostram que a combinação de metiformina
com berberina pode ter efeitos sim
sinégérgicos benéficos,
especialmente no tratamento da esteatose
hepática, da gordura do fígado e no
controle do açúcar do sangue. Então, a
combinação ativaria mais intensamente a
via de sinalização intracelular AMPK,
resultando em melhor controle metabólico
do que cada substância isoladamente.
No entanto,
existe uma questão importante sobre o
timing da administração.
Estudos de 2019 mostraram que a
sequência de administração influencia
sim a interação farmacocinética.
Então, quando administrada
simultaneamente, pode haver
interferência na absorção intestinal da
metiformina. Então, pode usar sim no
mesmo dia. Eu só recomendo que utilize
em horários diferentes, tá?
A microbiota intestinal também poderia
desempenhar um papel fundamental nessa
interação. Ambos os compostos modulam a
microbiota de forma similar e essa
alteração poderia influenciar o
metabolismo de ambas as substâncias.
Portanto, respondendo diretamente a
pergunta, não, a beberina não reduz os
efeitos da metiformina na prática e na
verdade pode potencializar,
mas também pode alterar a
farmacocinética de maneira às vezes
imprevisível. Então, a recomendação é
administrar com pelo menos 2 horas de
intervalo entre as doses para minimizar
a interferência na absorção e monitorar
mais de perto os níveis de açúcar no
sangue, pois o efeito combinado pode ser
mais potente do que esperado,
tá? Então eu utilizo essa combinação e
recomendo que você, se caso esteja
utilizando, continue utilizando. Só
utilizem horários diferentes para não
ter aquela interferência de absorção
teórica, né?
Próxima pergunta. Uma amiga após 14
sessões de aplicação de carbox lipo sem
corte deu um caroço abcesso na barriga e
não cicatriza por nada. fez todo o exame
pedido e não tem não tem nada que
atrapalhasse a cicatrização. Conhece um
caminho?
Bem, esse caso ele é um caso de abcesso
persistente pós carboxiterapia,
aparentemente, né? Requer sim uma
abordagem multidisciplinar. Então,
portanto, é importante entender que a
cabox terapia,
embora seja uma técnica relativamente
segura quando bem executada, pode
apresentar complicações em alguns casos.
Então, os estudos de 2024 mostram que
injeções subcutâneas de carbono podem
ocasionalmente eh CO2, né, que é o ácido
carbônico, né, podem ocasionalmente
levar infecções locais, especialmente
quando há falha na tecla estéreo ou
quando o paciente apresenta fatores
predisponentes.
Então, no caso da sua amiga, a formação
do obscesso sugere que houve uma
contaminação bacteriana no local das
aplicações e o fato de não estar
cicatrizando, mesmo com exames
aparentemente normais indicaria que
precisaria investigar fatores sistêmicos
que poderiam estar impedindo a
cicatrização.
Então, baseado nos estudos mais recentes
sobre cicatrização problemática, o que
eu recomendaria, né, de maneira bem
generalizada, né, obviamente tem que
personalizar de acordo com o caso dela,
uma avaliação médica,
seria verificar níveis no sangue de
vitamina C, de zinco, de vitamina D, de
magnésio, para ver se ela não tá com
deficiência de algum desses elementos.
Então a vitamina C é muito importante
pro colágeno, né, e pra cicatrização.
Então ela poderia tomar de 2 a 3 g ao
dia de vitamina C para ajudar na
cicatrização. O zinco é um
micronutriente muito importante pro
sistema imune. Poderia tomar por volta
de 15 a 20 mg de zinco alimentar
de um a duas vezes ao dia.
E além da função imunológica, o zinco
ajudaria na síntese proteica no local da
lesão. A vitamina D, vocês sabem muito
bem que é muito importante pro sistema
imune. Ela modula a resposta
imunológica,
promove também a formação de vasos
novos, angiogênese, para poder ajudar na
cicatrização. Então, teria que est
mantendo a vitamina D no sangue por
volta de 50.
E a oxiga, oxigenoterapia hiperbárica
poderia ser bem interessante para ela
cicatrizar melhor essa lesão, né? Então
isso é uma técnica muito utilizada para
cicatrização de feridas, que é muito
eficiente, tem excelentes resultados
e é liberado pelo plano de saúde e
liberado pelo SUS para essa indicação.
Então quando a gente faz o oxigênio em
câmera hiperbárica, ele aumenta a
pressão parcial de oxigênio no tecido e
facilitando então a cicatrização e
combatendo infecções anaeróbicas, ou
seja, bactérias anaeróbicas. Então,
protocolo seria vitamina C, zinco,
vitamina D, magnésio, ômega-3 e
cocumina, tá? Cucumina pelas
ações anti-inflamatórias.
Outra coisa interessante também seria
usar o óleo ozonizado na ferida, que tem
bons resultados para a cicatrização, tá?
pelas ações antimicrobianas e
próxicatrizantes.
Vê se essa pessoa não tá com resistência
insulínica, né, com pré-diabetes, que
poderia estar comprometendo a
cicatrização,
ou deficiências nutricionais diversas,
né, além do que eu falei, vitamina C,
zinco, vitamina D e magnésio, né?
Seria essas minhas dicas.
Tem muita pergunta hoje, gente. Eu acho
que eu não vou nem discutir. Eu vou
falar só o negócio lá do da nicotina
depois das perguntas, tá?
Conheci uma moça na academia, ela teve
COVID e ficou até entubada. Um ano após
isso da crise de ansiedade tão forte que
está tomando oceolíticos. Falei para ela
sobre azul de metileno e pessoal no
grupo falou de plantas. Por ser C19,
você sabe algo que ajude?
Então, a literatura mais recente do ano
passado, desse ano, tá confirmando sim
que até 70% dos sobreviventes da COVID
desenvolve sintomas persistentes, sendo
ansiedade um dos mais debilitantes e
especialmente em quem teve doença grave
com intubação.
Então, o estudo de 2024 mostrou que o
azul de metileno tem um papel promissor
nesses casos de COVID longa. O que o
azul de metileno atua como catalisador
hedox mitocondrial, redirecionando
elétrons na cadeia de transporte
eletrônico do NAD H para o citocromo C,
ou seja, ele faz o elétron pular uma
etapa lá na cascata fossfolilativa, né?
Então isso aumenta a atividade do
complexo 4 lá da mitocôndria.
E isso é importante porque ajudaria na
função mitocondrial e o COVID-19 é
caracterizado por uma disfunção
mitocondrial.
Então, quando as mitocôndrias não estão
funcionando direito, temos fadiga, temos
brain fog, né, a neva mental e temos
ansiedade.
Então, um estudo publicado 2024 mostrou
que a metilha não pode atravessar a
barreira hematofálica ou licórica,
restaurar a função mitocondrial
cerebral, aliviar sintomas neurológicos
do COVID longo.
E a dosagem, já comentei isso antes, é
05 a 1 mg por kg de peso corporal.
Eles estão dividindo em duas tomadas.
Em relação à fitoterapia, a achaganda tá
sendo testada em um grande estudo de
2000 pacientes com COVID longo no Reino
Unido. E ela ajuda sim, porque ela
adapta o cortisol, né? Então, pessoas
que tm cortisol alto, a chaganda dá uma
reduzida,
melhora a função imune,
tem propriedades atogênicas e a dose
estudada tá sendo de 500 mg duas vezes
ao dia. A rodola rosa
também tem estudos sendo feitos,
mostrando que melhora de maneira
significativa a fadiga e ansiedade
pós-viral.
Ela aumentaria a noradrenalina, a
serotonina e a dopamina no sistema
central.
E a dosagem seria entre 200 a 400 mg por
dia.
A passe flora encarnata, né, que é o
maracujá, teve eficácia comparável ao
oxazepan para ansiedade, tem ação
gabaic, então aumenta o neurotransmissor
calmante gaba e os estudos usam de 45 mg
a 90 mg do extrato padronizado.
E teve um estudo de 2022 que testou uma
combinação de adaptógenos, que é o caso
da rodiola, a esquisandra e leuterococos
em 100 pacientes com covid longo e houve
melhora significativa da fadiga,
ansiedade e qualidade de vida.
Existe um dado na literatura
interessante que começou a ser estudado
a partir do ano passado, que é a
depressão, ou seja, a falta do nada de
mais no COVID longo. Nada de mais é um
sinalizador, né, mitocondrial que
aumenta a energia mitocondrial.
Ele é praticamente um precursor, né, da
da moeda energética final, né, que seria
o ATP. Então, SAS COV 2, nesse caso, no
COVID longo, há o esgotamento dos níveis
de NAD mais celular. Isso causa uma
disfunção mitocondrial grave. O estudo
que foi publicado em 2024 mostrou que a
combinação de Nutrexona em baixa dosagem
de 4,5 mg com suplementação de nada mais
melhorou significativamente
os scores de qualidade de vida em 36
pacientes.
E quais são os percussores de nadis?
Nada demais, você pode comprar para usar
sublingual pela manipulação ou tomar o
precursores, né? A nicotinamida
mononucrotídeio que o o David Sinclair
popularizou muito aí, que é o NMN, ou a
nicotinamida ribosídio,
só que são suplementos caros, tá? E a
dose de NMN estudada foi de 250 a 500 mg
por dia,
OK? Então ela pode usar, a sua amiga
pode usar azul de metileno, pode usar
chaganda, pode usar rodiola, pode usar
nicotinamida ribosídio ou ninamida
mononicrotídio
ou até a vitamina B3, se ela não tiver
condições aí de comprar esses dois. A
cozima que é 10 sublingual ou biquinol
ou mesmo vioral, né? Poderia utilizar. E
o NAD mais também poderia ser uma
alternativa.
Ok?
H,
é azul de metileno na água. Pode ser em
cápsula também, Alice. Não precisa ser
necessariamente em gotas, não. O pessoal
tem essa obsessão de azul de metileno em
gota, mas não precisa. Pode ser em
cápsula.
Aparelhos com vapor de ozônio de salão
de beleza presta?
Aí a pergunta é muito abrangente, eu não
poderia te responder para saber de que
equipamento que esse salão comprou, tá?
Eu diria que se for um equipamento de
qualidade presta sim, tá? E outra coisa,
é um zone muito fraquinho, né? Esses
aparelhos para uso em salão de beleza
geralmente são aparelhos que tem uma
onização bem fraquinha, só para ajudar a
não dar infecção na pele, né?
Colocaram dois comerciais na live. Como
é que Eu não sei, não tô sabendo disso
não. Depois vou ver sobre isso, tá?
Como é que faz para colocar o comercial
na live? Interrompe minha fala. É isso
aí. Coloca um comercial.
Estranho. Não sabia que tinha isso não.
Boa noite, Eloía. Bem, antes da gente
terminar a sessão de hoje,
vamos falar sobre a nicotina.
Teve uma pergunta sobre nicotina que eu
eu resolvi fazer um texto mais longo
sobre isso, que eu achei um assunto
muito interessante, tá? A pergunta
especificamente,
deixa eu achar aqui,
eh, perguntando sobre vídeos do Dr. Dave
Asprey dizendo que a utilização de
nicotina na no diária de 2,2 mg seria
uma forma de estimular a longevidade,
tá?
pois agiria de forma
regular vias metabólicas que vão se
desregulando. Vamos lá, tá?
Esse assunto chegou a meu conhecimento
tem uns do anos, tá? E achei muito
interessante quando eu comecei a ouvir
sobre isso. Mas tem vários por aqui que
nós vamos discutir.
Primeiro ponto, a nicotina que nós
estamos falando não tem nada a ver com
nicotina do cigarro, tá? E nem o vapor,
né? aquele cigarro eletrônico. Nós
estamos falando de uma coberta
científica que saiu em 2023 na Nature,
que é as revistas mais respeitadas do
mundo. Então os pesquisadores
descobriram que a nicotina, obviamente
nicotina pura, né, tem nada a ver com o
cigarro, em dose 1000 vezes menores do
que era inicialmente reconhecido como
doses padrões de nicotina, doses muito
baixa de nicotina, então poderia fazer
algo extraordinário no nosso corpo.
Então, acabei de falar da molécula NAD+,
né, que é um dos precursores do ATP, que
vem da vitamina B2,
perdão, da vitamina B3, o FAD que vem da
B2. Então, sabe a NAD mais que todo
mundo fala no mundo do biohacking,
então ela ela seria o precursor direto
da ATP, seria como se fosse uma gasolina
premium para células. Então, quando nós
somos jovens, temos nada mais de sobra,
mas conforme vamos envelhecendo, os
níveis vão caindo e vão parecendo os
problemas, né? A pele fica mais flasta,
o cérebro fica mais lento e o
metabolismo desacelera.
Então o Dave Aspray, esse que você
comentou na pergunta, e é o sujeito que
ficou famoso quando criou o Bulletproof
Coffe, né? o café à prova de balas. Ele
é considerado um dos pais do biohacking
e ele usa a nicotina de um jeito bem
específico. Então
ele não usa todos os dias, é importante
dizer isso. Ele usa em torno de 1 a 2 mg
e ele usou poucas vezes em um espaço de
4 anos.
Então eu uso muito esporádico, não é
todo dia e nem toda semana.
E ele faz isso quando ele precisa de um
boost cognitivo para algum trabalho
importante, escrever um livro ou
preparar uma palestra. Então, como é que
funcionaria isso?
A nicotina em doses ultra baixas, tô
falando de doses aí quase homeopáticas,
ela ativaria, nessa faixa de 1 a 2 mg,
ela ativaria uma proteína chamada
cirtoína um ou sirtum.
E essa proteína é um dos maestros da
orquestra do envelhecimento. Então,
quando
a Cirtum está funcionando bem, tudo no
corpo funciona bem.
Sabe o que que é mais interessante?
Nessas doses bem baixinhas da nicotina,
ela nem precisa ativar os receptores
nicotínicos tradicionais. Ela atua
através de um mecanismo completamente
diferente que acontece quando alguém
fuma.
Então, os pesquisadores chineses do
Instituto de Tecnologia Avançada de
Shenzen fizeram experimentos em que eles
deram água com nicotina para
camundongos, uma concentração muito
baixa.
E sabe o que aconteceu? Os níveis de
nadimais no cérebro dos bichinhos
aumentaram entre 40 e 60%. Então, os
ratinhos ficaram mais espertos, a
memória melhorou e a neuroinflamação
diminuiu.
Então, temos que falar agora das
ressalvas, não é porque funciona que
todo mundo deveria utilizar a nicotina,
por ela tem potencial mesmo em doses
baixas para a dependência, tá? seria
como café, só que pior.
E você sabe que tem muita gente que toma
café e fica de boa, mas tem gente que
quando toma café fica viciado
e se não tomar cinco xícaras por dia
fica com dor de cabeça.
Então com a nicotina acontece um efeito
parecido, só que com risco maior. Por
isso que os biohackers estão sendo muito
cautelosos e estão utilizando muito
de maneira muito esporádica e limitada.
O Peter que é outro médico famoso no
mundo da longevidade, ele experimentou
usar 4 a 8 mg de goma de nicotina por
dia, mas depois ele parou porque ele
achou arriscado demais.
Já o Andrew Hubberman, que ele é um
neurocientista famoso de Stanford e tem
um podcast bem assim popular também. Ele
usa
ocasionalmente quando ele precisa de
foco extremo, mas sempre avisa que o
Vape de nicotina é tipo craque em termos
de potencial de dependência. Então é
muito risco de dependência usar a
nicotina. Por isso que esse pessoal tá
usando muito esporadicamente.
E sabe o Brian Johnson, vocês já ouviram
falar daquele cara meio excêntrico,
aquele bilionário que gasta 2 milhões de
dólares por ano tentando reverter o
envelhecimento.
Então ele testou mais de 60, mais de 70
compostos diferentes e ele não optou
utilizar a nicotina no protocolo maluco
dele diário lá. Então, mesmo esse cara
que é bem assim polêmico, né, bem
eh,
como é que a palavra? Eh, é excêntrico,
evitou de utilizar nicotina devido a
esse fato que eu falei para vocês aqui
da dependência.
E também tem uma outra pesquisadora
chamada Honda Patrick.
Ela não é a favor, é totalmente contra o
uso da nicotina.
e ela acha que a nicotina não ainda tem
dados suficientes de segurança,
então ela entende que não é o item a ser
utilizado.
Então, durante a pandemia,
alguns médicos notaram uma coisa
estranha. os fumantes estavam menos
representados
entre pacientes hospitalizados com COVID
grave.
Então isso era totalmente
contrainttuuitivo, né? Um cara que fuma
deveria ter mais risco de ser
hospitalizado grave com COVID. Então
isso gerou uma hipótese colinésica
chamada hipótese colinérgica nicotínica
e tem até hoje estudos em andamento
investigando se a nicotina poderia ser
um elemento protetor contra o COVID. Mas
de novo, não recomendo utilizar nicotina
para isso.
Mas voltando ao Nad mais, quando a gente
envelhece o NAD mais despenca.
Temos menos NAD mais nas mitocôndrias,
são usinas de energia, como vocês sabem,
e elas começam a funcionar mal.
E é como se o motor do carro começasse a
engasgar.
E aí aumenta o estresse oxidativo, os
danos ao DNA e o declínio cognitivo.
Então a nicotina em dose ultrabaixas
poderia reverter isso através de
mecanismo que os cientistas chamam de
via sirtium n PT nada demais.
Então é um negócio meio complicado, eu
sei, mas imagina.
É como se a nicotina destravasse uma
porta que permite que o corpo produza
mais nada mais naturalmente.
E o mais impressionante
é que isso acontece
com dose 1000 vezes menores do que as
doses que ativam os receptores
nicotínicos normais.
Então tem gente tomando pastilhas de
nicotina de 2 mg cortadas ao meio, meia
pastilha uma vez ou outra quando
precisa. Outros estão utilizando
adesivos transdérmicos cortados em
pedacinhos.
E isso tá muito ainda no início, muito
experimental e considerado até perigoso,
tá? Então não é algo que você deveria
fazer sem acompanhamento em casa.
A nicotina pode aumentar o gasto
energético em até 10%.
E é como se você queimasse 200 calorias
a mais por dia sem fazer mais exercício.
Ela ativaria também o tecido adiposo
marrom, que é aquele tipo de tecido
gorduroso,
que é a gordura boa que queima energia
para produzir calor, que é aquela
gordura que tem mais em criança,
pequena. E os estudos mostram que
animais tratados com nicotina tiveram
21% menos gordura corporal.
Mas antes de sair tomando nicotina para
emagrecer, lembre-se dos riscos que eu
já comentei. Os riscos não compensariam
os benefícios nesse caso.
Falando sobre a questão da dependência,
ela é muito séria. Estudos mostram que
mesmo com dose de 1 a 3 mg por dia, se
você utilizar de forma contínua sem
parar, tem um risco importante. E o
limear perigoso parece ser de 5 mg dia.
Acima disso, os níveis de de cotinina,
tá, que chama, tá, os níveis de cotinina
no sangue,
que é o metabólito da nicotina,
chegam num ponto que indica potencial de
dependência.
E a dependência pode se envolver em
questão de dias, não de meses.
Tem efeitos então cardiovasculares da
nicotina.
Mesmo em doses baixas, pode aumentar
pressão arterial em 5 a 10 mm de
mercúrio, aumentar a frequência cardíaca
em uns quatro batimentos por minuto.
Isso para quem tem problema cardíaco é
um problema.
Então, eh, seria mais uma
contraindicação ao uso da nicotina.
E se fosse utilizado, precisaria de
monitoramento médico rigoroso.
Comparando com outros compostos
antienescimento, a nicotina tem as suas
vantagens e desvantagens. Por exemplo, o
NMN, que eu já comentei em outro
outra pergunta, né, que é a nicotinamina
monucleotídio e a nicotinamina
ribosídio, que são precursores diretos
do NAD Mais custam entre 50 e 200 por
mês. Isso fora, né, nos Estados Unidos.
A nicotina custaria de 11 a 72,
mais bem mais barata.
Só que o NMN e o NR, que é a
nicotinamida ribosídio, não tem
potencial de dependência.
Lembrando a metiformina que pode ser
utilizada também como medicamento
antiencimento que não tem esses
problemas. Nós falamos aí da nicotina.
Porém, aifomina não tem os benefícios
cognitivos, né, que a nicotina teria.
Eh, como vocês já sabem, né, os fumantes
gostam muito de tomar café. Isso tem uma
razão, porque eles têm ação sinégérgica.
Nicotina com cafeína tem essa questão da
cafeína potencializar os efeitos
atencionais da nicotina.
E tem um dado interessante aqui que a
combinação de nicotina com liteanina,
que você sabe que é o aminoácido do chá
verde que aumenta o foco, poderia
reduzir o potencial de dependência
enquanto mantém esse foco. Então poderia
utilizar então a liteanina para reduzir
o risco de dependência na nicotina.
Então, base tudo isso que eu falei para
vocês, eu não recomendo uso, tá? Eu acho
que é bem perigoso para pessoas em
comum, comuns assim, utilizar a
nicotina.
É sempre importante fazer o básico,
exercício físico, alimentação adequada
antiinflamatória, sono bom,
gerenciamento do estresse,
tudo isso daí é o básico, né? E não tem
risco de dependência.
Se alguém depois de muito estudo e com
acompanhamento médico resolvere tomar a
nicotina, o protocolo mais seguro, mais
conservador seria 5 mg, 1 mg, no máximo
duas vezes por semana,
nunca diariamente com pausas regulares e
monitoramento constante
e sempre com a consciência de que tá
lidando com a substância altamente
viciante.
Porém, cientistas estão estudando outros
compostos parecidos com a nicotina sem
esses problemas.
Um deles seria os moduladores seletivos
do receptores alfa 7 nicotínicos, que
poderiam dar os benefícios sem ter o
potencial de dependência.
Então, vamos aguardar
os próximos capítulos.
Então essa informação que eu passei para
vocês que as doses ultra baixa de
nicotina que nem chega a estimular o
receptor nicotínico poderia afetar o NA
demais. É mais um exemplo de que alguns
medicamentos ou drogas que utilizadas em
doses completamente diferentes das doses
habituais podem ter efeitos
completamente diferentes. É como é o
caso, por exemplo, naxona de baixa
dosagem, que eu já uso há muitos anos e
que tem um efeito totalmente diferente
naxona de alta dosagem. às vezes menos é
mais. Então é um princípio que a gente
tirou da homeopatia,
mas que agora se encaixa muito bem
nessas drogas reposicionadas, né? Tanto
medicamentos em doses mais altas, como é
o caso da vimectina, quanto medicamentos
em doses muito mais baixas, como é o
caso do LDN ou da nicotina.
Graças a Deus, a ciência do
envelhecimento tá evoluindo numa
velocidade muito boa e estamos tendo
informações cada vez mais recentes e
cada vez mais interessantes.
Mas tomar muito cuidado com as
novidades, porque as drogas pouco
estudadas podem ter efeitos colaterais
ainda não
devidamente estudados, como é o caso da
nicotina.
Lembrando que cada corpo é único, que
funciona para um, pode não funcionar
para outra pessoa, né? Então, mais
importante é ser o mais personalizado
possível.
Beleza, pessoal? Então, já estamos com
uma hora de live.
Bem, eu vou verificar isso aí, tá, Maria
Helena, para ver se eu consigo desativar
esse esse comercial aí, beleza? Mas
qualquer coisa vocês podem também ver o
vídeo depois, como vocês sabem fica
gravado, né? Então se você perdeu alguma
parte da minha fala depois volta lá e
assiste novamente.
Bem, pessoal, muito obrigado pela
participação de vocês. Um abraço, um
beijo no coração e nós nos vemos na
próxima semana.